Hello everyone and welcome to Citizen by CNN This
is today's spotlight is on the final push. The
final sprint, the final rush, The final, whatever
you wanna call it to the midterm elections,
this is CNN's civic engagement platform and we
are less than one week away from the 2020 midterm
elections. So we're going to In the next 45
minutes give you the full picture of where things
stand right now. We're going to avoid predictions
because friends don't do that to friends.
Um and we're going to look at what the polling
says, what the candidates are saying as they
are in the midst of their closing arguments
of course. Um joining me today is CNN's vice
president of political coverage. CNN's political
director, David, Chalian uh Frederica Schouten
national political writer and contributor to
the CNN citizen newsletter and jen agiesta,
CNN's director of polling and election analytics.
The genius behind the scenes of everything that
we put together and how we all get it on air and
accurate so we're gonna jump into questions and
start this conversation. But we also do want to
hear from all of you out there watching so you can
submit your questions in the box to the right
of the player um and we're gonna get to those
shortly. But let's jump in. Okay, so perfect day
for us to be having this conversation as we CNN
as we put out some really important and revealing
new polling um out today. It's a snapshot gen of
where the race is now, what voters are focused
on. It's everything from the generic ballot two
most important issues to voters from enthusiasm
to also confidence in the election results. What
do you think is most important coming out of
this new survey um that we released today?
Yeah, I think that we are seeing in these new data
really the continuation of the trend that has been
building over the last couple of months. Right.
We're looking at generic ballot where Republicans
have a narrow edge 51-47 among likely voters in
our numbers today. And we started to see that
shift toward Republican in our polling earlier
this fall where we found um Republicans with an
edge and competitive congressional district. Um,
and I think that, you know those that's all driven
by these economic headwinds that are out there,
people are deeply concerned about the economy.
They feel like the country is already
in a recession. Um, and all of that,
combined with fairly negative approval rating
for president, joe biden, all of it sort of comes
together and produces this sort of Republican tilt
as we're in the final stretch of this campaign
and David, you've been out kind of showing many of
the various aspects of the poll that are sticking
out to you and kind of the change over time. What
do you think all of what the polling that we put
out today and as the change over time, what it
says about where we are now and how the race
has shifted in this cycle. Yeah, I mean, as jen
just depicted for you, I do think what the poll
shows is that this is a pretty sour mood that the
electorates in thinks the country's way off, you
know, in the wrong direction and, and things are
not going well. Um, and, and that obviously tends
to speak to a change election kate as you know,
um, the fact that biden is underwater, as jen
mentioned, never bodes well for the President's
Party when more people disapprove than approve of
his job performance when it comes to midterms and
the fact that the economy is the dominant issue
and that's an issue advantage for republicans. You
add in that we see this enthusiasm advantage for
republicans and that's sort of the snapshot
now. You talk about the change over time.
You know, this, I feel like we have returned to
where this cycle started, which is sort of the
historical norm because at the beginning of
this year, I would say january through May.
Um, this is what all the polling looked like,
like joe biden was increasingly unpopular. You
saw republican edge in the generic congressional
ballot. The economy was becoming a very dominant
issue in not a good way for the incumbent party.
Uh, and, and so then what happened was the Supreme
Court overturned 50 years of precedent by
getting rid of roe versus wade in the Dobbs
decision and that ignited the Democratic Party
and the Democratic base and it uh and democrats
just uh politicians, candidates just went all in
on that issue over the summer. And what we saw is
that really galvanized democratic voters and
they started expressing enthusiasm about the
election and they started feeling a little bit
better about joe biden, I guess. Uh you know,
they felt that they had a really worthy fight on
their hands uh to start rallying around uh their
own in a way that they have been not doing in the
earlier part of the year. And then as distance
has occurred from the Dobbs decision, it's not
that it's not being talked about, democrats are
still spending a ton of money kate as you know, on
advertising, leaning into the abortion issue. Um
Vice President Kamala Harris, President joe biden
even in recent weeks have given campaign trail
remarks on this topic. But when you look at poll
after poll, it just doesn't compare to the economy
in terms of the salience for voters as the most
important issue. And so as the gas prices tick
back up as the economy has become more important.
And as time has gone on from the Dobbs decision,
I think you see that's why you see these trends
back towards the republicans. Yeah, it's it's
kind of the momentum in the winds is maybe this is
this back to the future, Is that the definition of
back to the future in terms of electric? I don't
know, we can debate that a little later. A drink.
One part of the poll that came out today, but I
know you've been looking at heavily and it's a
huge thing is half of americans say that they're
at least somewhat confident the election results
will reflect the will of the people. But also that
also means half of americans are expressing little
or no confidence in the election in the election
results. Is that glass half full or is that glass
half empty? Oh Gosh, it's hard to tell. I mean, I
guess the good part is that the people expressing
confidence in the election, more people are than
they were during the summer our last poll and over
the summer show that about 42% of people felt
that that that they were confident about the
election results. It's been so striking to me
because I've been covering sort of what's been
going on with election administration all year.
And there is a The whole ecosystem of people out
there who are who have made it their business
to cast doubts on the 2020 election results.
And I think that we're seeing the fruits of
that. I think the big question is going to be
how people behave after the election, you know,
will candidates concede, will people accept the
results? And I think that that's still very much
an open question in some parts of the country
absolutely. Before you jump to. Sorry, can we just
just think about what Fredricka just results may
not be accepted? That that's an open question
I think speaks to and it is clearly an open
question and it just speaks to the fragility of
our democracy. I think it's, you know, why you
see president biden tonight gonna be giving this
address from Union station on on democracy? Not
because he thinks it's the issue that is going
to win the election of the democrats. I think
the White House's eyes wide open that this is
an economy election and talking to my sources
inside the White House, that is the case. But they
believe this is a critical mission for a president
who ran on restoring the soul of the nation. That
this can't be an open question if we're going to
have a fortified strong democracy. Sorry, I just
wanted to know I was gonna say, but add to that,
jen, what's the partisan divide on this question?
Yeah, there's a really large partisan gap between
Democrats and Republicans on this. We've got
like a 20 point divide in terms of lack of
confidence in that American elections reflect
the will of the people right now. But I would
note that that is a pretty dramatic shift from
where we were shortly after the 2020 election.
Um, and I think there is some push and pull here
in the partisan views on this, depending on what
is happening in the political environment at any
given moment, in january of 2021 shortly after,
um, you know, the presidential election after
january 6th, uh, 75% of republicans said that they
lie Confidence, that elections reflected the will
of the people, compared with only 9% of Democrats.
And that's obviously narrowed dramatically since
then. And that might be because Republicans are
seeing the same polls that we are, and thinking
that there might be Republican success in this
upcoming election. Even with that, you still
have Republicans more likely than Democrats in
our new polling to say that they don't feel that
candidates who lose elections in their states
have an obligation to concede or to say that they
think um candidates of their own party challenge
the results of an election after they lose, are
actually doing more to increase confidence in the
democratic system than they are to decrease
confidence. And that's a that's a partisan
difference. That's their sort of across the board.
Yeah, I mean, and and David, on the partisan
divide, I was looking, I just pulled it up, 39%
of Democrats, of independents, 59% of Republicans
say they don't necessarily have confidence. And
what does this mean for next week? It's it's an
unknowable, but it's scary. It is, I mean, you
know, I think we should look at how many people
that have called into question election results
from 2020 actually win uh this year in the very
same system. Our election system. It's the very
same system. You know, if if if the Kerry lake
or Mark Finchem running for uh secretary of state,
if these election deniers from 2020 win, you know,
are they, they're just gonna accept these results
and there's gonna be no explanation why the system
is okay this time around. But I mean like when
elections your your election is fine. I mean,
we saw that even in 2020 right election deniers
saying that the election was rigged and Joe
Biden did not win except they thought their
congressional race was fine. Precisely. We did
see that a lot in 2020 and and of course that
holds no um logical weight. I mean, you know,
and so but just to put a finer point on this, our
poll showed right two thirds of Americans overall
believe that Joe Biden was legitimately
elected president of the United States.
The when you look at just republicans self, I
did republicans as they answered that question,
two thirds of republicans do not believe that joe
biden was legitimately elected President of United
States. And that is the rub that we're in right
now when one of our major political parties um is
not bought into the concept of accepting election
legitimate election results as legitimate,
this gets to and jen I noticed your, your sign
your tagline your bumper sticker over your
shoulder, this is accurate verse because this gets
to one of your question that came in. Um, Sheila
from Virginia is asking as we have definitely
asked many times over the cycles, she writes,
I'm an independent voter who is concerned with
the accuracy of the polls. Are the polls accurate?
Well, I wish I had a good answer for Sheila. I
would like to think that they are. I think that
pollsters are taking lots and lots of steps to
try to correct for the errors that we have seen
in past cycles. I mean, obviously, the
problems that polling had in 2016 and in
2020 were extremely well publicized.
Everybody's aware that there was an
of the Republican support and a lot of
polling in both of those election cycles.
Um, and pollsters from all across the spectrum,
the partisan pollsters, the nonpartisan pollsters,
everybody has tried to do as much as we can to
investigate the sources of those problems and what
it ultimately boils down to is, um, something
that we nerds call differential non response,
which means that people who have one political
view are less likely to respond to your poll
compared with people who have a different
political view. And so to control for that,
to try to make sure that we're getting the right
mix of people, pollsters are paying more attention
at the front end on who they're reaching out to
when they're doing surveys. They're using voter
lists and whatever information they have about the
geography of where you live and political behavior
in that area to try to make sure that we're
getting the right mix of people in our polls.
Um, and I do think that we as an industry have
made strides on that. Um, can I promise that the
results will look exactly like the polls do right
now? I cannot do that. But, um, I do think that,
um, we are seeing progress made within polling
to try to better reflect the political reality
of the United States right now. Just to make
the point when you say the right mix of people,
you mean so that it is truly representative of
the whole, right? I mean, it's the right mix
of people is not somebody's random desire of
what the right mix is, the right mix is being
who like to drink orange juice. Exactly.
I mean, you know, there's this constant,
um, back and forth between sort of pollsters
and people who don't do this where they're like,
well, why don't you just pull half democrats and
republicans and call it a day? And it's like,
well, that's not really what the country looks
like. There's a different mix of that. People's
partisanship shifts. You have independence.
There's a lot to to account for. And it goes
beyond that. And we're also looking to make
sure we have the right mix of people by gender,
by race, by age, um, by geographic region, by
level of education. All of those things are really
important for us to consider in assessing the
validity and representativeness of our samples.
So I have a question, I've been thinking about
this today and looking at the this 50 50 split.
Um if people have confidence in the
in the election results Fredricka,
which is if people aren't confident in
the election result, that it will reflect
the will of the people, are they just not
going to vote? Um And is there a connection
between a lack of confidence and a desire to
actually vote? What do you think about that?
Well, I think what we're seeing so far in
the early voting is that people are voting.
Um the latest numbers we have today for 46 states
shows that Nearly 28 million people have already
cast their ballots. And we're seeing higher rates
at this point than we did in the midterms in 2018.
Um one of the things that we're not quite sure
about yet is whether people are sort of shifting
their voting patterns. Let me give you an example
in Georgia. For instance, in 2021, the Georgia,
General Assembly passed a law that really changed
how voting worked in the state. Um and so it made
it a lot harder to vote by mail. Um and it also
made some changes to what's going to happen. on
election Day itself. Um for instance, you can't
cast a provisional ballot anymore and have it
count if you go to the wrong precinct on Election
Day. So what we're seeing as a result of that is
some candidates and third party voter education
groups are encouraging people to really vote early
in person. So is that shifting the numbers that
we're seeing? I mean, we still don't know yet
how this feeling about voting will change
voting patterns at the end of the day,
you know, when the final count is in. I
don't think we have the final answer yet,
David, what's your what are your thoughts and
deep feelings about just this huge level of early
voting that we that we're seeing in places
across the country, like like in Georgia?
Yeah, I mean, I do think uh You know, we
compare things to the last midterm to 2018,
but that's like a different universe since
it was pre pandemic, right? So we saw
um the voting behavior change unbelievably
in 2020 because we were still in the midst
of the height of the pandemic in many way. And
so we just radically changed the way we vote
in America so many people voting by mail and
absentee. What I think we're expecting to see
this time is that that ratio of sort of election
day voters to pre election day voters. It won't
look like 2018 or anything prior, but it won't
look as totally uh skewed to pre election voting
and absentee voting the way 2020 was, it's
gonna be somewhere in between those things.
Um, but what occurred as you know, in 2020 is
that partisanship informed so much about the way
in which people voted. And so as Fredricka
saying like, does that pattern continue?
Um, you know, we anticipate right that democrats
tell us and surveys and the like that they are
more likely than republicans to vote before
election Day, vote by mail, vote early in person.
What have you and republicans are more likely
than democrats to vote in person on election Day.
So knowing that we have these two different
universe, political universes in the way in
which people vote really is important, understand
as you watch the vote returns come in on Tuesday
night because how each state or locality counts
their votes whether or not they're voting,
they're counting and reporting out all the early
vote first or the they're counting and reporting
out all the election day vote first. It can make
the results early on look extremely favorable to
one side or the other. But actually when the rest
of the votes get counted, that could potentially
narrow quite a bit, if not actually reverse
course. Absolutely. I mean, David, you and I
were on the phone constantly just in 2020 I was,
I was reporting on the ground in philadelphia and
on the presidential election and as we know in
pennsylvania, they can't even open the mail in
ballots, the early, early votes like that. The
mail in ballots until that morning. And that
really slowed down that process. You'll remember
of getting that tallied and there was a huge kind
of shift, oh my God, the things that you, you guys
were calculating, you and jenny and decisions on
what that didn't want to anticipate it is um, it's
pretty amazing. I mean, it also talks about how
mail in voting and when you can actually open up
an envelope should be changed because for the ease
of all of the hard working election workers on
election day. But I digress, we actually do have
that is not we like we do late night, this is what
we do actually. That's gonna be our final question
of that. One thing I'm gonna get to it a little
bit later. But there is a viewer question on this,
jen, just in terms of comparing to 2018 as David
was talking about chuck from florida was asking
specifically about this, how does early voting
turnout in Georgia Arizona pennsylvania? Wisconsin
compare between 22 to 2018 2020? And what do you
think the cause of any of the changes in voting
behavior? Is it something that David was getting
at? But it's, what are your thoughts on it?
I mean, I think a lot of what David said is
what I'm seeing in the data. I mean you have,
um, this kind of rebound almost back to 2018, but
maybe not quite as as much a reversion back to
Election Day voting. Um, in some of those places,
especially a place like Arizona or Georgia where
early and by mail voting was a fairly well
established process before the pandemic hit.
Um, So, you know, you see a little bit of
a rebound in there. I think the thing that
we're seeing some evidence of in polling and
perhaps partly in some of the partisan splits
that we're seeing um is that Republicans, even
if they are voting early, might be voting later
in the process and returning their ballots
later. That was a lot of what you saw in the
Arizona vote count after election day because
the way that they counted in 2020 was that,
um, they counted all the mail stuff that they had
before Election Day and then they counted their
Election Day votes. And then on top of that they
counted the ballots that were returned in those
final days and those were more republican than
the mail ballots that they had received early.
And I think you might see a little bit of an
exacerbation of that pattern in what's happening
this year, where those late arriving ballots
might look a lot different than the early arriving
um arriving ballots. Um, Certainly in some of
these places, you have changes in voting patterns
that are driven by changes in the law. You know,
in Georgia, they changed the early voting period.
Um, and in some places they made it a little bit
harder to vote by mail to sort of shifts people
toward early in person. Um, but really, you know,
at the, at the end of the day, the big picture of
what we're going to see here is that those votes
that are cast before Election Day because of this
polarization of voting methods are going to be
more democratic. And I think it's highly likely
that that's going to be, um, A bit of a bigger
divide than what we were seeing in 2020. And
the ultimate question is whether the, you know,
the, the number of votes that are cast early,
um, make that Look even more dramatic and
how the numbers shift on election night,
than than they did in in 2020 or even to
some extent in 2018 and Frederick, a huge
part of Post election activity in 2020 related
to some of what people thought, you know,
and related to challenges with kind of the
process that we're talking about right now. All
the legal challenges to the vote count in various
states. I know that this is something that you're,
you're tracking and looking at and preparing for
this cycle. Are you seeing some of that already?
Oh yeah, we're definitely seeing a lot of
lawsuits. I think it's about 100 and 50 have been
filed so far and people are just litigating over
how the vote is happening, how it will be counted.
Um And you can you can almost see in advance
some of the challenges over provisional ballots
or I mean one example is the Republican National
Committee has five I think about 75 lawsuits so
far and a lot of them deal with poll watchers and
poll workers. The party has has made a big effort
this year to make sure that there are Republicans
who are hired to work in polling places
and also making sure that there are lots of
partisan poll, watchers people who are who are
representing the party or a candidate and making
sure that they're watching the process all the
way through as people vote. And you're seeing
a number of lawsuits right now from the R. N.
C. Challenging the procedures uh for you
know how close poll workers poll watchers
rather can get or how many poll workers have
been hired in a particular jurisdiction.
Um You're also seeing a lot of challenges
over what happens with ballots that are maybe
incomplete. For instance in pennsylvania, the
state Supreme Court ruled just yesterday that
if people fail to put a a date on the outside
of their absentee ballot that cannot be counted
and must be set aside. Um So it's really
important that people in pennsylvania make
sure that they follow instructions thoroughly
and completely if they're voting by mail. But
you can see that this is setting up sort of lanes
for legal challenges in very close close races
in places like pennsylvania and in places like
michigan if you can say no, those ballots can
be counted because this procedure was not followed
during the election or in the counting. Um I think
you're just, I think this election is gonna have a
very long tail and they were going to see a lot of
post election litigation and we may not know the
final results and ultimately, who controls the
the U. S. Senate and the in the U. S. House for a
bit as a result of all this litigation. Yeah, I'm
having real flashbacks when you're talking about
making sure you date the envelope real flashbacks
to 2020 under Flynn. Um let's let's talk about the
important issues. This is big and pulling and it's
this is the gets to what really is the closing
argument and what what messages are resonating
Um with voters in our poll, the list of the
most important issues was the question to
voters topping the list is economy and inflation.
At 51% say this was their most important issue
this cycle, abortion after that at 15% voting in
elections. That's 9% gun policy, 7% immigration,
6%. Climate change, 4% crime, 3% jen what do you
think this list shows? I mean the economy is so
front of mind for americans right now and that's
partly because they are dissatisfied with their
own financial situation. And you can you can
pretty well connect that back to inflation and
where we are um With rising prices, it's been a
top concern just consistently for the last year in
survey research and it's, it's driving everything.
We had 55% of Americans in our new poll saying
that they are dissatisfied with the way that their
own personal financial situation is 75% say that
the economy is currently in a recession
that's up significantly from this summer.
Um and so they just are feeling like uh the
economy is in a bad place. And at the same time,
we have about two thirds saying that president
biden is not um focused on the right priorities.
He's not paying enough attention to the country's
most important problems and those things all
connect back to the economy and are making it such
a strong and driving issue for so many people.
David, do you think this finally settles that
Carville's line about it's the economy stupid,
is always the case when an election cycle
occurs when it's a tough spot in the moment
of the economy or people feel that it's a tough
spot in the economy when they're going to the,
when they're going to vote. Yeah. I mean, with
that caveat that you just add at the end like,
yes, we've seen elections that I don't think
are all about the economy. I think that I think
back to the 2002. midterms the year after
9, 11. And I think that that was, you know,
largely a national security election. And
And and so I I do think there are times,
um, even 2004 that presidential race between
George W. Bush and John Kerry, I would argue,
um, was a bit more about a national security
election. But yes, when Americans are feeling
and pinch that, that, I mean, that's why
they call it pocketbook issues. I mean,
it's just like that is so present at your
kitchen table every night. It dominates
every aspect of your life, right? Like, I mean,
you're you're trying to budget and figure out
with increased costs. Do I now have enough to
cover um, a child care expense as well as uh, you
know, another priority. Perhaps a health care bill
or what have you? That that is just a real daily
thing for so many. That it's hard. How could that
not be top of mind? Right? And I'm not suggesting
that crime or uh immigration or abortion rights or
the fundamental strength of our democracy are not
important issues. They all obviously are important
issues, but I don't begrudge the american voter
for dealing with the most acute immediate concern
in front of them first, which is what they're
dealing with at their kitchen table every night.
And this is this is what it comes down to in
the tightest races and the most closely watched
races across the country, Let's talk about some
of them. Let's focus in on pennsylvania. Since I
clearly very focused on pennsylvania right now,
David, I don't know, I might be, I might be in
pennsylvania, I don't know, I might be headed
there. So, as I'm asking questions, I'm also
taking notes. Um the Fetterman versus Oz race.
Um it has been a tight race for
quite some time. It has also been
there have also been like almost tv script
like surprises and turns in this race.
Um that it's just been kind of remarkable.
What do you see in that race right now, David?
Um Well, I'll use here, I'll use the example
of what the candidates are closing on in their
television ads to to show you where I I think
that reveals where the race is right now. So,
um john Fetterman went up with an ad yesterday,
that is a classic of the genre. Pure contrast ad
just uh like I will bring you the truth memory.
Oz is gonna lie to you memory Oz is gonna bring
his lies to Washington. It is all about trying
to drive up Oz is negatives right? That to me,
shows that reveals to me that the Fetterman camp
believes they have to have Oz take on some more
water here with voters than he currently has.
The flip side is that Mehmet Oz went up with an
ad and and is spending millions of dollars
to get into living rooms of pennsylvanians
across the commonwealth to reach out to the
middle, to be sort of a kindler gentler Oz,
not the trump endorsed Oz of the primary, who ran
to the right uh to get the nomination. But now,
understanding in this general election
contest, in a battleground state to be
talking about that Washington in general
doesn't get it, gonna bring some common
sense solutions that can bring people together
um and lower costs, you know, for pennsylvanians,
what have you? It is a it is an outreach
message. So he sees, it seems to me a real need
um to grow beyond whatever republicans he's
galvanized around his candidacy to make sure
that he is taking on more and more independent
and even some democrats into his corner here. So
I think that's sort of I think those ads are just
so instructive of where, because you don't spend
millions of dollars on stuff, if you don't think
you're going to move some voters, and I just think
it reveals where they see themselves right now
and what they have to do from now through Tuesday,
what do you see, what does that tell
you in pennsylvania? I think the
polling um it's really interesting on the
favorability front. I mean, there are memories,
has much more negative views in pennsylvania
among likely voters than uh john Fetterman does
we've seen sort of a range in the polling there,
but very, very little polling that suggests that
um memorizes currently ahead. So I think that
that sort of um puts us at a starting point where
Fetterman maybe has a little bit of an advantage.
But the question is whether he can hold on to it
and as David was saying, playing up memorizes
negatives, there is really um, Probably the
most the best, the best strategy that he could go
with given what we're seeing in the polling there
right now. And so Arizona, this is another Senate
race. That is key to the balance of power, which
by the way include everyone. Every seat is the key
to the balance of power when it's a 5050 split.
Um, we've got Mark kelly versus blake masters.
Um, and Fredricka, there's also been surprises
in this race, which is one of them being, I mean,
it's just a surprise and also just like another
interesting twist which masters on the phone
reassuring donald trump as he was being filmed
as part of a documentary that in promising that
he was wasn't gonna let up on the rigged election
claims. I mean, the conversation that you hear
from the trump side is just wild and he's like
look at Carrie meaning Kari Lake is running for
governor who's an election. Denier carries winning
with very little money. And if they say, how's
your family? She says the election was rigged and
stolen and that is what trump is advising him you
have to stay on if you want to win. And he says
that he's that he would continue on and he's not
going soft on it. What is going on in that race
Fredricka? Well, it's a very competitive race um
like a number of them across the country. Um one
of the things that you have to remember is that
Arizona has really been ground zero for this like
election denial fervor keep in mind last year,
there was in Maricopa County, an entire recount
organized of by the Senate republicans of the
results in Maricopa County because there is such
a feeling in that state false though, it may be
that the election was stolen because of widespread
fraud. So I think what you're hearing in this
trump Masters conversation is an acknowledgement
that that's where a lot of the GOP base is or at
least some, I can't say a lot, but at least some
of the GOP base in Arizona and that you need to
motivate them to turn out. Um you're seeing in
the form of Kari Lake who's running for governor
Blade, Masters Mark Finchem who is running for
secretary of state. This this line of thought that
you have to be firm on election denial denial and
that um that this is what people are getting
worked up about and I mean, one of the things
that we've seen in Arizona and there have been
some court cases about this this week is people
who are so worked up about election conspiracies
that they have shown up outside bala boxes and
are accusing people of being mules that is turning
in ballots on behalf of others. There was a court
ruling just last night in which a judge says no,
you've got to stop that. Do not show up with a
gun or with physical tactical armor within 250
ft of a ballot drop box. But I think that that
gives you a sense of how fervent some people feel
about what happened in 2020 and I think that's why
you're having that conversation between the former
president and and the GOP nominee for the Senate.
Absolutely. So in the final couple of few
minutes that we have, I wanted to ask you guys
about your sense, just kind of on timing. Um not
a prediction, but more just a sense David of how,
what should people expect in terms of how long it
may be to have the full picture of the results,
um how long it could be before people really
understand what the balance of power in Congress
is gonna look like. Um we remember very clearly
in 2020 that we had to wait until the weekend
um to have the presidential race called. But this
is this is different in terms of the laws that are
triggered for the for some of these races in the
midterms, What's, what's your expectation or what
are you preparing for? Right, well, general, give
us the exact to the minute and second day as to
when this will happen. I do think, I do think
Kate as I urged viewers and readers in 2020,
uh, pack your patients. I don't, I don't know. I
don't believe quite frankly that we will have the
answer to which party is going to be in control
of the United States Senate when everyone goes
to sleep Tuesday night. I just think, given
the nature of what we understand about the
pace of counting and how when states can begin
processing in the critical battleground states,
whether it's pennsylvania Arizona Nevada
and given where the polling is of how close
these contests are, I just, it would be a big
surprise to me if we had the complete picture
um, of what is going on with those vote totals
to a sufficient level to understand project and
understand control of the United States.
And I just want to remind everyone also,
It could come down potentially depending on
things go to Georgia, which has a December
six runoff. And if indeed, the control of
the United States Senate is hinging just
on the outcome of the Georgia Senate race as
it did after 2020 with those two run offs,
uh, that occurred in early January 2021. Uh, you
know, were then we're in, we won't know for weeks.
Um, so that is a distinct possibility as
well. Uh, in terms of the House might,
I don't know if we'll know Tuesday night or not,
and I know there's a lot of critical house races
in places like new york and California that
tend to uh count slowly all of their votes.
Um but if, if our poll today and it sort
of matches all the polling out there,
I'm not just putting this on us. Um if the
environment between now and Election Day only
gets increasingly advantageous for republicans
and this enthusiasm advantage really turns out,
um then it may be that republicans are winning,
uh such a number of seats that are able to be
projected, remember they're only five away right
now, uh from the majority that maybe we'll have a
clearer sense of at least which party will control
the house, I don't think we'll have a sense of how
big that majority will be for that party. Right?
And, and jen maybe, I mean, give me your thoughts
on this as well, but I know, you know, pack your
patience is, I mean, that's really what it's
going to be. Well, no, we know right. And that I
think leads to something that, I mean, it's it's
something you have done many times and, you know
very well, but I think people really might enjoy
um if you can peel back the curtain a little bit
and take people behind the scenes of just what
is happening on the CNN decision desk throughout
Election day and into the evening as the results
are coming in and kind of what that coordination
and choreography and um communication is like that
eventually leads to Wolf saying stand by for a
key race alert or stand by. We have a projection.
Yeah, it is, it is a very um extremely complex
dance the entire way through and what we're
looking at and what we're looking for really
changes as um as the night goes on and as the
week goes on. I mean, I think uh David mentioned
and you mentioned earlier, you know, the in a 50
50 Senate, every single race is a key race. And I
think that the ones where we are seeing the most
competitive battleground right now in pennsylvania
in Arizona and Nevada data in Wisconsin and to
some extent in Georgia, these are places that um
tend to have more prolonged counts um and where
figuring out what's going on within that count
might be a little bit trickier than some other
states. So um I feel like, yeah, I would agree.
I think the Senate, there's, it seems highly
unlikely that we're gonna know on election night.
What we are looking at on election night is what
we're seeing come in, the geography of where that
comes from. What types of votes do we have and
what can we say about them with definitively? You
know, Georgia is um great at reporting both the
um breakdown of votes among election day voters
and a breakdown of votes among by male voters and
early in person voters? We can look at all those
different pieces of information whether the size
of those groups match up with our expectations
and really put together a good picture of what we
think is happening. And the size of the margin is
the main thing that's going to determine when and
how we can make a projection in Georgia um, in a
state like Nevada, they don't really tell us what
we're looking at. So we don't know necessarily if
the votes that we get early are strictly by mail,
if they're early in person, if they're Election
Day. So there's a little bit of um, I shouldn't
say a little bit, there's a lot more wait and
see happening in a state like that where we
don't really know what it is that we're seeing the
geography of it drives quite a lot. But we really
do need that extra vote by method data to be able
to say for certain what it is that we're seeing.
Um, so we're looking for all of those pieces,
we're looking, we're wondering as we see things
that look like they might be Project Herbal,
what could we possibly be missing? What looks
like it's an outlier here. Is there any, um, you
know, typo that some election officials made in
some place that overstates votes for whatever,
Uh, county it is, it makes it look bigger than
it should? You know, we're comparing it to past
elections? Wait was it in where was it you guys
when we the someone went to someone's house
and woke them up because they had like gone
home with the sheet. Oh my gosh that was such a
good in 2012 Republican Iowa caucuses in 2012.
I think what someone on CNN convinced them to
go wake them up, wake their colleague up to get
this. I mean it's like you can't make this stuff
but I guess he does deserve. It was very smart.
Yeah. So we're looking at all these different
pieces of information when election officials
can tell us what they actually have left
account how much of it is there and you know
what does that do to our statistical models and
our our calculations of the certainty that we
have in what we think is going to happen down the
road. I mean it's it's literally a math problem
which I know journalists never want to spend too
much time doing math. But that is that is what
we're doing because doing maths over and over and
over again. Yeah, there's certain journalists who
do math. We do not do we do not try to do math
on live tv though. We like to leave it to the
geniuses behind the scenes. Um I know we had, we
had a colleague who once always wore remember the
Adidas the Adidas slippers? The Adidas sandals
on election night? Do do, do you guys have,
is there like a, do you have like a thing like a
accuracy first pair of socks that you wear, jen? I
do not. The accuracy accuracy first sign actually
belonged to that colleague with the slippers that
I inherited. So oh gosh, I don't really know if
I have any kind of special thing that I do. One
of my colleagues on the decision desk cannot get
through an election night without a very large
case of mountain dew. I'm more of a
diet dr pepper person. So we'll have,
we'll have lots of caffeine that will be
helping us through. But what about you?
Um, I don't have, you'll see me in a purple
tie. I wear purple ties on election days
just because you're pro swing state. Is that
exactly? I okay, Fredricka. What is your plan
for election night? Oh, well, I don't have
any special outfit unfortunately. Um, I will
be paying a lot of attention to what's happening
with election administration. Um, that's gonna be
what I'm focusing on. Are there problems in some
stray counties that will delay the certification?
Um, because I've been following folks who've been
denying the 2020 election results all along. So
I'm going to be paying attention to those places
where they're likely to have an influence on this
election night? Yeah, I feel like Fredricka,
there's like, jen, jen and David are gonna be
slammed all day and then you start, you like take
the ball and then from like election night beyond,
it's like, all right Fredricka, you take
this from here. I'm just watch the magic.
So, okay, you will be responsible for letting us
know when pennsylvania will deliver the critical
batch of votes. I mean, I feel like again,
back to the future, just keep asking them how
many provisional ballots they have. I had so few
friends in philadelphia with the people I had was
like, no, no, Wake up. I need to know what so what
we do, what we do, they love us because we're so
um, we are so kindly, very forceful in
our reporting. Um, great to have you all
here. Thank you so much for joining us. And gen
David Fredricka uh, this was fun. Thanks guys.
Um, we all really appreciate it, joe viewer very
important for more content about the upcoming
election. Go to CNN dot com slash election slash
2022. That's where all the action will be online
leading up to and after election tonight.
Thanks you guys have a great day. Thank you.